6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish. I'm Phil.
And I'm Georgie.
Some people remember their school days as the best time of their lives.
For others, it was the worst.
Did you enjoy school Georgie?
Most of the time, yes.
But there was one thing I didn't like.
The school rules.
Luckily, that's not a problem for pupils at the Bamboo School in Thailand.
Because there, the children, not the teachers, make the rules.
Children at the Bamboo School are responsible for every part of running the school,
from buying food for the kitchens to disciplining fellow students,
and even hiring new staff.
It's a school run by students for students.
Yes. In this programme, we'll be hearing about the Bamboo School,
a unique school where the children call the shots.
They have the power to make the decisions.
We'll also be learning some useful new vocabulary.
And before you ask Phil, yes, the Bamboo School really is made of Bamboo.
Sounds good, Georgie.
But first, I have a question for you.
The Bamboo School is a private school for poorer children who can't afford school fees.
Bamboo school children get educated for free,
but have to do something in return.
But what?
Is it A, teach lessons, B, plant trees, or C, learn English?
Hmm, I guess they have to learn English.
Okay, Georgie. I'll reveal the answer at the end of the programme.
The idea behind the Bamboo School is simple.
Teaching children responsibility by letting them run their own school.
The school doesn't employ cooks, gardeners, or cleaners.
It's all done by the pupils.
Twice a week, children go to the vegetable market with a school officer
and buy food for all 150 students.
The prices are then carefully checked by other students like Nuneem
who manages the food accounts.
Here's Nuneem speaking with William Kramer,
reporter for BBC World Service programme People Fixing the World.
I am interested in accounting to begin with,
so I get excited by it.
When I actually get to do it, I enjoy it a lot,
since we are doing the actual job.
With this hands-on experience,
we see the schools real spending and the things we purchased.
So you went to a local school before, just in this area.
What are the differences between that school and this school?
My old school was like this.
It was just classes and then home.
Here I get to try so many things,
get real-world experience,
and work on my leadership skills with my friends.
I've never had these opportunities before,
and the school has been amazing.
Nuneem says shopping at the market is a hands-on experience.
She's actively involved in doing something practical
rather than getting someone else to do it.
She enjoys managing the food accounts
because it's real-world experience.
The phrase real-world describes how the world works in reality,
rather than someone's idea of it, which might be unrealistic.
Children at the bamboo school get opportunities
to try something new and different outside the classroom,
increasing the chances they'll find something they're really good at.
Of course, there are some adults.
If we school these teachers,
but what's special is how children are trusted
and respond positively to that trust.
Here's reporter William Kramer, again,
speaking with Myra Anubi for BBC World Service Programme,
people fixing the world.
So just to be clear,
it seems like the grown-ups are still in charge in the classrooms,
but outside it's the kids who run stuff.
Yeah, I think that's broadly right.
And I think one of the things that's interesting about this school
is it manages to be quite conventional in some ways
and really innovative,
it will even radical in others.
At the bamboo school, the grown-ups,
another word for adults,
are still in charge in the classroom.
But it's the kids or children who run everything.
It's a radical idea and means that besides lessons,
there's lots of work to be done.
Children do two hours of community service.
That's work that is done without pay
to help people in the community every week.
Anyway, I think it's time to reveal the answer to your question.
Yes, we just heard that kids go to the bamboo school for free,
but do something in return.
But what?
Georgie guessed it was learning English,
which was the wrong answer, I'm afraid.
In fact, pupils at the school have to plant trees.
400 of them every year.
Right, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned from this programme
about a school where the kids or children call the shots.
A phrase meaning have the power to make the important decisions.
Hands-on experience means being actively involved
in doing something practical,
rather than just talking about it or getting someone else to do it.
The phrase real world is used to describe how the world really is.
Rather than someone's idea of it,
which may be unrealistic or untipical.
A grown-up is an informal word for an adult,
and a kid is an informal word for a child.
And finally, community service is work that is done
without pay to help people in a community.
Once again, our six minutes are up,
but remember to join us again next time
for more trending topics and useful vocabulary.
Here at six minute English, goodbye for now.
Bye.
Six minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com.